yesterday we had the general manager of
the tampa bay buccaneers jason light on
the show and now we have
one of the best wide receivers in the
business um
he's in super bowl champion now and he's
about to go hit the free agent market
potentially
he is chris godwin back here on the rich
eisen show how have you been chris
oh man i've been great i appreciate you
guys having me no absolutely
i gotta one one of the many reasons why
i wanted to have you on
uh is because uh the nfl
films um i guess snippet or
uh uh bite if you will from the super
bowl of you and your fiance celebrating
on the turf together i love that that's
that's
i live for stuff like that i i live for
journeys
travel together uh whether it's athlete
and parent or athlete and and
you know partner or future spouse in
your case
i love it you and your fiance were
celebrating what was that like for you
chris man it was uh it was unbelievable
you know like you said like that
just like you know the the culmination
of the journey that we've had together
uh you know we've been you know been
together like 10 years now
so like you know she's been with me
through thick and thin
you know and that's my rider dying for
her to be there to share that bubble
with me on the field
it was just uh just culmination oh that
was unbelievable i know you were mic'd
up and i
i i just you know i i ate it up and um
and and so now that you have gotten the
super bowl
i mean what what does it feel like to be
a
super bowl champion chris i like i like
the sound of that man
every time i hear you know i just i just
get excited because if you know like as
a kid right for at least like for me uh
you know my two biggest goals were you
know to make to the nfl and to be a
super bowl champion
um and to have accomplished that uh you
know both of those by the end of my
fourth year
um it's just it's such a blessing you
know because there's there's so many
talented guys that
you know that haven't had the
opportunity to to get to this point
and so yeah it's a blessing you know no
of course i'm sorry
i didn't mean to cut you off there i
thought you were um you were completing
so
so um and you know obviously michigan
men like myself like completing to
people like you
what was that like to be uh on the end
of tom brady's
passes play calls in the huddle with him
all year long
chris oh i was so dope man like just
watching him like my entire life
and being you know seeing him from afar
and watching the greatness and then
now having the opportunity to be a part
of that you know like now i'm a part of
that history
um it was so cool you know and he was he
was so different from
uh i really like anything that i had was
anticipating
you know i was just kind of like like
thinking that he was going to be like
this stifler like just ball ball ball
all the time
you know and and and don't get me wrong
he loves the game of ball
and he puts so much into it but like off
the field
you know he's he's a great guy you know
he he really just came in and fit in as
one of the guys you know cracking jokes
to
just the whole night and you know you
have nothing but respect for a guy
that's so accomplished but comes in and
it works as hard not harder than
everybody else and
um how does that permeate the locker
room how does that permeate the huddle
how do you pick up on on what he was
putting down
chris godwin yeah i mean it's infectious
man um
you know like when you when you go out
there you go to battle and
and and your your leader is putting in
everything he has
you know and he's going to give it his
all it you
you you feel obligated to step up and
answer the bell
you know we we're going into every game
expecting the win
knowing that you know we had all the
pieces that we needed to be successful
it just was going to take some
some growing throughout the process and
you know we went through our growing
pains and
and you know some people weren't
doubting us but i think the great thing
is that the men in the locker room
never wavered you know like i said we
had full belief in everybody that we had
that we had the piece that we needed to
go out and make the run that we did
well when did it all come together chris
god when the the sense
uh might you know is now that we're
looking back on it could have been
uh after the first quarter of that first
game against the chiefs week 12
after tyreek hill had a quarter to
remember
uh but the way the rest of that game
went into a bye week out of which you
never lost again
is that it or was there another aha
moment for you
and the team i don't know if there was
one
one specific moment but i would say like
right around that time period
was when i would say things started to
kind of like click right
we had like at that point we had our
backs up against the wall
and i think you know you made a good
point in that first chief's game
you know they got up on us really fast
and and
the teams of the bucks teams of the past
you know very well would have laid down
um and just like dang like you know like
they got us this time
you know like they're just a better team
but the the
the fight that we had in that game to to
come back and have a chance to really
you know put ourselves in position to to
win that game at the end versus the
defenders who both champions
i think they gave us a lot of uh
confidence like that we needed
as a as a team that had been together
for the first year really um
you know trying to put it all together
and then you have the bye week and then
you have
atlanta where we started off you know
slow again but at that point it's
literally like
we're playing for our playoff lives you
know that we we treated that game
in the rest of them as playoff games you
know and it's like if that's the
mentality you have
then it literally feels like winner go
home for you and we had
and we had to approach it that way super
bowl champion wide receiver
pro bowler chris godwin here on the rich
eisen show okay so now it's about
decisions
uh let's talk decisions chris first one
up um
if i you have you have to make one
choice here uh i give you a choice of
going horseback riding with devon white
or
tequila shots with tom brady which one
do you do which one you can actually
which one would you do i'm gonna go i'm
gonna go horseback ride with my boy
devin white i
had never been on a horse why not let's
go let's let's hit the trail ride man
yeah but i mean you know riding an
animal is
you know not the same as just you know
throwing back avocado shots and clearly
you know there's a support system with
tampa uh to to deal with
maybe too many of those shots as we saw
chris
there's a ton of support here for guys
like that
you know i i think i i think we've done
that let's go ahead
let's give let's give the trail ride a
little a little shot
okay let's do that now then uh well by
the way great use of shot
uh right there okay now let's talk about
i guess the more important decision
the more life-changing one in front of
you free agency how are you approaching
this
right now chris godwin um
really i've really just been taking it
you know day by day uh
because like at this point right like
it's um
it's out of my hands at this point at
least in terms of uh until
march 9th right like if the team decides
to franchise like me then
then that's what it is you know and
that's what it would be um
but obviously you know i'm looking you
know for some security
looking you know for uh an actual deal
you know and and and i guess we'll cross
that bridge when we get there
but um i love it here man you know i
love
i love the team love the city love my
guys i love going to war
battle with them um so i guess we'll
have we'll have to see how everything
plays out
now i had i had the gm on yesterday
jason light he said nothing but glowing
things about you
has there been conversation between
management and your and your
representation
yet chris yeah yeah yeah i believe so
you know and and i think i think those
conversations will continue to
will continue to happen you know i like
you know it's no surprise to me that
that the
uh interest is mutual on both ends but
you know at the end of the day we all
realize that it's a business
you know and in the same way that
they're going to approach it they can
make the
uh decision that's best for them as
a business as an organization you know i
got to do the same thing
um and obviously all of it out of
respect all right and is it possible
that uh
have you enlisted the help of somebody
who um
wearing the number who that you used to
wear to potentially lobster and
lob something in to say hey let's see
what we can do to keep 14 here
anybody i'm not responding no i have i i
have not but you know i would imagine
that there
that there's been conversations like
that you know we all like everybody
there has so much like so much respect
for each other and
you know i think we all have like such a
great working relationship that
um you know i don't know if there's much
lobbying that needs to happen at this
point
okay chris godwin here on the rich eisen
show let me get into that actually the
uh
the the jersey stuff uh do you hear what
michael pittman had to say in
indianapolis this week about his number
11 and carson wentz did you hear about
that
yeah i did i heard about it a little bit
okay that might have crossed your ear
gate
um what did you think of that um
hearing from michael pittman um again
he's a second year player and we also
know carson wentz has not been with the
team
what do you think about him saying uh i
i'd like to keep my number 11.
chris what about that oh i thought it
was interesting uh
you know like i'm i'm not surprised you
know not not too many guys really want
to get up that number
um and i think each situation is very
different you know i think
the situation he's in is completely
different from the one that i was in
um and that's not to say that either one
of them is the right one
i just think that like for me it made
the most sense for me to give up my
number
you know what i mean and like just like
out of respect for tom and for what he's
done and
you know hoping that maybe one day that
i will get that same perspective needed
later on down the road
um you know and and and michael
he may not think that same way you know
which is cool and and also
i think it is worth noting too that
carson might not
want number 11. and so then then there's
not really a story at all
no i i know that chris apparently
according to michael that that that
carson reached out to ask for it and
then
said yeah i might want to change it
anyway after being told no
and it's one of those situations you
know uh where you don't want to
you want something but you don't want to
make a big deal of it after the other
person
kind of forces you to maybe make a big
deal of it you know and it's one of
those things
to avoid conflict i'm a conflict of
order normally in real life that's so i
kind of understand that but
did did uh did tom ever ask for it you
just coughed it up
chris yeah no we uh we he he asked for
it um
and and we had and we had like we had a
really good conversation too um
and and i think that was uh it was good
though because
that was like one of our first like real
conversations you know we were like
talking on facetime about
just a bunch of different things and and
we're going over it and uh
and like i said it just made the most
sense and you know looking back on it
if uh you know someone said hey if you
give tom number 12 and you go with
number 14
that y'all won a super bowl i do that
every single time
without without question well chris i'm
not questioning your decision making
whatsoever okay i'm just wondering how
it went down did something
um other than the jersey exchange hands
chris godwin one more time did something
other than the jersey number exchange
hands
oh no no no no it was it was it was
really just out of respect though um
because like i don't know like i said i
would i think for me
like um i think i'm big on on just you
know
doing things the right way and and
trying to trying to be a good person
you know um and i really do believe that
like things happen for a reason and
you know like i said hopefully down the
road you know if i'm looking for
you know in a situation like he was that
i would get that same respect
and then it's like all right well
everything came full circle pay it
forward
and now you'll be looking down at your
hand at some point and seeing that big
shiny object and it's like you made the
right decision chris godwin
that's it bingo
you know i mean that is just going to be
a great great moment for you
did brady bruce arians told me a couple
minutes left here with chris godwin
uh bruce erin's told me that brady spoke
to the team night before
can you um pull back the lid on that a
little bit what did he say to the team
night before the super bowl chris yeah
um
you know he it was um it was really
really impressive to watch
like that you know the culmination of
all of
all that right because he you know he's
talked throughout the season
you know here and there but he's never
really been much of like a like a
pre-game you know
rah-rah guy he usually let you know
devon and lavonte take care of that oh
yeah
um but like throughout the year the
entire week of the super bowl you know
he was texting us
you know like though two weeks you know
the entire two
weeks like almost every night you know
with different
uh you know different film clips
different like motivational stuff and
just really just hitting like god like
like we like we're made for this moment
like we're gonna win this game
you know and and just constantly like
feeding like that confidence to us that
we know that the moment is not too big
for the guys that we have
you know and and i think that that
really just
not only spoke to just like how intense
the moment was and how confident he was
but like that it spoke to just how
comfortable we should be as a team
you know like we had earned the right to
be there and we shouldn't just go in
there like oh like we're happy to be
here we go we should go in there with
the approach that
we're going to win this game you know so
you're saying
every night um for two weeks before the
super bowl
uh what pops up any i'm assuming known
sender on your phone
was a group text from tom brady um
essentially to what to to
to a whole bunch of you the whole team
with what movie clips
phrases what was that what was it really
uh like the
mainly the skill position guys right
like okay you know running back tightens
receivers quarterbacks
uh and just different like you know like
different like motivational stuff like
whether it's like from like from himself
like directly or like it's like film
clips it's like like little reminders of
hey like
you know like when they do x y z you
know we do this
you know what i'm saying and just like
just a reminder that like
that he's constantly working and that we
should be confident in ourselves as a
group
to go in and like regardless of who
we're going against like what we're
facing
you know as big as the task was that
we're we're going to be good
you know well you know chris uh what
about
you as i finish up what about you
because at some point you know
we're assuming brady's not gonna play
until he's 105
um and or you will be on
for whatever uh reason um maybe on
another team
um you know it could be multiple
millions of dollars worth of reasons but
um so at some point you know you will
have that challenge in front of you do
it without brady
um so long story short what about you
your goals
for you chris godwin in your career here
um that's a great question um
i mean for me i i think the goal is
always to do
you know what we've just done um i think
the the more that i'm entrenched in in
this game
and you know the more fortunate that i
am to continue to play
the more i realize just how important it
is for me like to win
um you know like i've been you know like
last year we
we had a decent year you know but it
wasn't good but you know by our
standards
you know like we're seven and nine but
and i have like you know i had
an all pro season but it didn't it give
me you know anywhere near the
satisfaction
that winning this super bowl did you
know even though my numbers were down
um you know so like for me it's doing
all that i can to make sure that
whatever team i'm on
is in the best position to win you know
and along the way
learning from the tom brady's you know
the mike evans you know the bronx
just from like picking their brains and
allowing me to absorb all that
information so that i can then
pass that out to you know whatever
teammates i have moving forward because
like at the end of the day
we're all just kind of like recycling
information and passing it all like to
you know future generations to keep
furthering the game
and i want to be a part of that and i
like i want to continue to be a champion
well i hope you get what you want chris
um i imagine it's to stay put where you
are
uh where you like to be where tom
brady's your quarterback and
and um you'll have an opportunity to
maybe
you know box cameron braid out for the
next trophy toss from boat to boat you
know
um exactly you know like uh again you
can't
i mean a tight end brait i mean my god
great grab
uh that was impressive so hopefully you
get to keep hopefully you get to do that
yourself
you know and um did you hold on a second
did you drop your pho
tj jefferson my social media grandmaster
just passed me a note
did you drop your phone in the water i
did the boat my phone
got the ball is that the bottom of the
tampa river
[Laughter]
i i pulled up my phone to go live
which i never do you know and will not
do
any more and like we're standing on to
on the firm boat
and i see like at the corner of my eye
like i think i see scotty start to kind
of stumble
and in my head i'm like man like i'm i
can't let scotty go into the water you
know we can't get another scotty we
can't
lose him out here
and in the process you know my phone got
knocked out of my head
and went right into the water and it was
like it was like it was a slow motion
like i was like no
and like looking like this like a police
boat next to us and they're like
watching they're like no i'm like but
like him one of y'all get that like
what's up
and uh it it went down really fast it
was so bad
but uh you know my my folks at rising
looking out for me so i i was very
appreciative of that well good
good shout out uh but um that doesn't
bode well for
the next trophy toss chris i mean no
it does you know what i would say though
is is the trophy is much bigger than my
phone okay
okay but equally as valuable in your
mind i'm sure
uh more valuable it's a lot easier to
get a new phone and there's a new
lombardi
so ask ask him the poll question before
going out the door
oh this is perfect for chris godwin
chris brown
all right chris godwin two gigantic
birthdays today would have been steve
jobs 66
birthday phil knight founder of nike is
83. who's had the bigger societal
influence oh man
that is a great ques i would have to say
steve jobs
i would have to you know i i think
you're
you'd be you'd be it'd be a lot easier
to find someone with an eye with an
apple product
than someone with a pair of nikes yeah i
mean if if an air jordan gets thrown
overboard you just get another one
that phone goes you're freaking out
you're freaking out you'll go barefoot
before you lose your phone
i got a bunch up in the closet you lose
your phone you're like oh man i'm in
trouble yeah
the whole identity's ruined until you
get a new one
you're freaking out if if you get a new
one
see that's what i told you where does it
currently stand right now
it's 80 20 right which is what 80 80 20
steve jobs oh because i put my thumb on
the scales what you're complaining about
i would like to point out we're all
wearing nikes in the studio
i'm just saying and i am i am also
exactly listen listen if it wasn't for
steve jobs who knows
if we're having this conversation
we also all have mac mac yes
the answer is all of the above but
that's not a choice hey chris congrats
again
thanks for the call let's do this again
soon i appreciate you guys y'all be safe
right back
that's chris godwin everybody hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that
watch more right here